[Musique]
la sphère française maintenant avec tout
d'abord cette information étonnante qui
divise la ville de versailles qui ne
devrait pas tarder à créer un sujet de
polémique dans tout le pays
c'est l'affectation d'une aile entière
du château de versailles et des
logements type hlm vous dire que le
bâtiment était désaffecté depuis que la
ville a besoin de logements
mais cet après-midi un certain nombre de
manifestants le non pas du tout entendu
de cette oreille
jérôme monier a mené l enquête ont mes
fesses de cuisinière ici sur la place
d'armes
depuis que les versailles et hot afrique
une partie du château de versailles
allez être transformé en immeuble à
loyer modéré pour accueillir des
logements hlm
cette décision a été prise conjointement
par l'office des hlm et par les
monuments historiques dans le cadre de
la campagne pour la réhabilitation des
immeubles anciens
inutile de vous dire que cette décision
est fort controversé ici et si vous le
voulez bien nous allons ouvrir ensemble
ce dossier brûlant
c'est de cette aile nord qu'il s'agit là
des ministres construite par mansart et
restaurer au 19ème une aile fermée aux
visiteurs qui abrite maintenant les
pompiers
les travaux ont commencé pour y aménager
77 logements sociaux auxquels on
accédera bien sûr par la rue je trouve
tout à fait lamentable que tout les
bâtiments anciens beaux connu soit
soient vidées de leurs de leur sens de
leur destination et soient transformés
en lieux morts
je le ressens comme ça en tout cas
pourriez vous nous donner une idée du
contenu de ce projet oui bien sûr alors
les pièces du premier étage qui ont une
hauteur sous plafond très importantes
doivent être aménagés en duplex en
sous-sol nous aurons quelques salles de
réunion une salle de jeux pour les
enfants
et puis bien sûr il faut aussi
transformer au moins une partie du parc
qui l'a encore été conçu pour que le roi
sa course est invité il voulu pour pour
s'adapter aux besoins des nouveaux
habitants
c'est à dire petit jardin conçu gère où
chacun pourra planter ses légumes
ces fleurs et où un contact avec la
nature très proches pourraient être
établies du comité national de défense
du château a été constituée il ya déjà
réuni 25 mille deux cents signatures à
travers la france ait déposé un recours
en conseil d'état
pour nous il s'agit maintenant d'une
course contre la monte quand il s'agit
d'obtenir l'annulation du décret de
classement avant que les gens m'en
ménages
on comprenait bien qu'on pourra pas les
expulser après nous avons justement
rencontré dans un immeuble insalubre du
vieux versailles l'un des futurs
locataires veilleur de nuit 29 ans père
célibataire vivant depuis cinq ans dans
15 mètres carrés avec ses deux fils
j'ai fait une demande de watchmen et
puis je viens de recevoir une une lettre
que je suis à trois jours le 10 ans donc
que j'avais je les avais bénéficier d'un
appartement extra alors oui dans château
d'auvers-sur-oise moi ça m'est égal si
vous voulez
moi ce que je cherche c'est un logement
parce que vraiment avec les petits
surtout vous avez vu la porte au riad et
il ya même en plus des cds fuite
lorsqu'il se met à pleuvoir tradexpress
salubre temps devoir ménager
alors ça je ne sais pas j'ai téléphoné
donc lorsque j'ai reçu la lettre ma
victoire est très bon m'a dit que je
pouvais emménager d'ici six mois un an
ou alors la seule chose que je puisse
vous dire à ce stade du journal c'est de
ne plus appeler pour tenir des logements
dans 7 pays hellène puisque vous venez
de l'entendre il ya une procédure qui
est en cours
[Musique]